i heard that scott went to
rehab by seeing it online and it looks
like someone at the facility
leaked a photo of him and i feel really
bad for him
remember back in may when scott disick
checked himself into a rehab facility in
colorado
then quickly checked himself out after a
photo of the reality star at the
treatment center reportedly leaked
online
hey is that true what
about scott yeah well now in a new sneak
peek at the upcoming season of keeping
up with the kardashians
scott's ex kourtney kardashian talks all
about that with her sister kim
and calls the breach of trust quote so
awful
they leaked his actual conversation
with the therapist you know he's only
been
just him in the therapist he said he's
never been more betrayed in his life
and he is packing and he's definitely
coming home
but he's really upset and especially
that he was actually
going to work on something like traumas
in her confessional court said whoever
leaked the information should be
really ashamed of themselves everyone
deserves to deal with their tasks
traumas and
privacy he was completely violated at
the time the president
and ceo of all points north lodge issued
a statement to et
explaining that the protection of their
clients personal and confidential
information
is of the utmost importance adding quote
if it were determined that any
information relating to any client was
ever obtained from apm facilities and
provided to a media outlet
apn will take all legal action available
against that individual
back in may a source told et both court
and scott's then girlfriend sofia richie
influenced his decision to seek help for
substance abuse issues
at the end of the day scott needs to be
clean to be around his children
and family and that's everyone's main
focus right now
scott sobriety and the kids having a
healthy father
but this wasn't scott's first time
seeking help
i mean there's so many different things
that could pull you in different
directions
but at the end of the day i mean you
just want to be happy
you want to be content you want to be
comfortable in 2015
he entered a rehab facility in malibu
for a month before checking out
marking his fourth known attempt that
year
it was definitely a process during a
2016 episode of keeping up with the
kardashians
kim and chloe talked about scott getting
help he wants to really get it together
and wants to go to rehab for a long time
and i think that it all sounds amazing i
just hope that he sticks with it
he's like i'm eight days sober and i
just want to
you know really get it together this
time like for my kids that's good
and in a previous trailer for the
upcoming episodes of the family's hit
reality show
scott opened up about struggling during
quarantine
i'm starting to get a little stir crazy
the famous family has had to shoot a lot
of upcoming episodes at home themselves
due to the coronavirus crisis and in the
new clip
we get a peek at kim and quartz
self-taped confessionals
okay i just want to show you guys that
in the guest room we have set up a
confessional
and i still am filming keeping up with
the kardashians but shot
all on iphones back in april kim shared
a behind the scenes look at that
confessional shot
i am the camera person i am the lighting
person i am hair and makeup
so i'm going to try to figure this out
and she revealed how they were making it
work
there is clear instructions
it says power on here i know i can do
this
power on
okay the monitor should go on there it
is
we have our lights okay you should see
two levels on the monitor uh labeled one
and two
and if you're talking you should be
bouncing up and down okay
one and two i don't see that one and two
am i blind the struggle is real
it's a lot of us filming but in our
individual homes
either on tripods where you just set up
and go and it was
very different and awkward and we're so
used to being in each other's faces so
it's
different in july kim's little sister
chloe
dished on shooting the show without
their crew during a chat with siriusxm
hits one's the morning mashup i
thought i pushed record once and i
didn't i'm sitting there like having a
whole
confessional to the camera and yeah
nothing happened
i just kind of [ __ ] up
you